there's no place to be right now but in
it but fry the pigs
dr king is dead there is no one in the
black panther party who would have
spoken to the chairman of the party that
way
period so that that's number one
my name is elaine brown i am a former
leader of the black panther party in the
years
1974-1977 i've been asked to
take a look at some hollywood films
where the black panther party is
depicted
and to give my thoughts and review of
those
films
shut that blonde man and get your white
away from that window
don't you know we in a war here hey man
he's cool he's cool he's one of us let
me tell
in america loves forest gump and so the
shame of it is that
this one encounter that forrest gump has
is with
this insane cult group of people that
doesn't like white people well of course
it was a caricature and it was certainly
demeaning
not to count inaccurate well nobody
walked around wearing that stuff
every once in a while we'd have those
rallies in the early days
where people would wear you know the
black leather that was our sort of
uniform but nobody would be walking
around the office
with that clothing on the black panthers
are against the walls and vietnam yes
we are against any war where black
soldiers are sent to the front line to
die for a country that hates them
the vietnam war was launched in 1965 by
lyndon johnson
the party itself started in 1966
that we were the only black organization
that was actually a part of the anti-war
movement
then in my particular case in 1970 i
visited
hanoi and other places and did a radio
interview with a figure called hanoi
hannah
and we urged our black brothers throw
down their weapons
and come home sorry i had a fight in the
middle of your black panther party
so to make light of it to make a joke
out of us
then we become a caricature and a joke
there's nothing you can say about it
that's good
at all as to what was the black panther
party in any depiction of it
and if you were to rank it which you
know i was just so typically american
western thinking
that everything has to be ranked um but
if you were to rank it i don't think it
it's on the chart it would be below one
there's no place to be right now but in
it but fry the pigs
dr king he's dead bobby was very dynamic
bobby still was the chairman and
co-founder of the black panther party
but i can tell you this there is no one
in the black panther party who would
have spoken to the chairman of the party
that way
period so that that's number one but i
can't imagine
anybody uh any sister or brother
telling the chairman of the black
panther party what to do or not
i said it would be impossible for me to
care any less
what you are tired of and i demand to
cross-examine
the witness and the fact that uh he
would have spoken out in this
style would have been absolutely true
there's no way you would have told bobby
not to speak up in the courtroom
because that was almost the style of the
black panther party
and not for arbitrary reasons don't be
afraid to speak don't be afraid to
not follow their rules and so forth
uh we were pretty pissed off about it
when bobby was gagged and bound
he was treated so incredibly differently
than the others
i thought it wasn't a bad film as a film
because it was
more in tune with the times we just need
to make sure that nixon black power
doesn't equate nixon with the black
panthers you lost your mind matt did you
read hoover's last memo on that it's my
point
god damn terrifying no no no i gave him
the green light to gut those sons of
[ __ ]
i had forgotten about the butler i'd
written that out of my memory because
that was another one of those films i
refused to see
uh why don't we just have put aunt
jemima back on the pancake box or
uncle ben back on the rice box you know
this time we take a stand against these
injustices
that have plagued our community they
take one of ours
we take it to it if they kill one of us
we kill two of them i mean just kind of
simple-minded rhetoric um this is not
something anybody would have ever said
why would we never have said it because
it didn't make any sense that didn't
mean we wouldn't defend ourselves
but nobody's going out and saying well
we're going to kill
two of them for every one they kill and
all this kind of stuff we're not going
to allow
the police to come drive communities and
shoot people we will move on them and we
will do that but that wasn't the
essential thing we've seen this morning
for seven years now everybody just i'm
sorry mr butler i didn't mean to make
fun of your hero
everything you are and everything you
have
because of that butler now this wouldn't
have happened in anybody's universe
period period you hear me to i
the idea that this
woman oprah can play a role where she
flats a member of the black panther
party gives
hollywood and white people such comfort
knowing this isn't the way black people
are that we don't like them either
not even now we don't like them we don't
even like what they stood for
they were wrong they were terrorists
they were killers
this man was a good solid brother
who took care of his family and didn't
bother anybody
and he should have been respected by his
disrespectful son who joins the black
panther party
it's just so shameful to
try to show and to embrace the idea of
the good black
versus the bad black and in this case
the bad black
what's the worst oh black panthers so
the point is there are so many
inaccuracies in this concept
not to count that the boy of that man
was never in the black panther party
but the main purpose of that stupid film
was to elevate the role of the good
servile negro overall
my mind and body to the greatest extent
possible
i will learn all that i care the black
black dancing party the breakfast for
children program was not the centerpiece
of the black panther party first of all
it was a tool that the ideological
underpinning
was to bring people together and to
recognize that they had a right to eat
you have a right to food and and we
still see that today
we talked about the right to medical
care we talked to right to food
clothing all these things that right now
are still a problem so as a black person
when you look at this situation then as
now you find that we have the highest
rate
of prostate and breast cancer deaths in
america
and then we said well people are dying
because they have no access
to even the most minimal medical care
and so we said we have to
put clinics up but we have to show
people that you have a human right
to access to health care and the reason
we set free
is because we wanted people to
conceptualize the idea
that in a humane society we're not going
to make people pay
for those things that keep you alive
so i think that fred hampton recognized
that because he was ideologically very
strong as i knew him
unlike the director of this film and his
friend ryan coogler
i knew fred hampton and i knew that he
was very much
ideologically aligned and understood the
purpose of all of these programs
this is why the chicago police would
come in and assault our clinics you know
there in chicago they took some
very heavy hits on breakfast programs
and so forth
uh because the fear of j edgar hoover
which he stated openly
it wasn't that we had guns or nobody was
afraid of our guns
what do we have compared to the chicago
pd
or the illinois state police that
murdered fred or the united states army
or the united states navy or the united
states marine corps or the united states
air force or the cia or the fbi or the
atf
and all the other agencies of this
government that are armed to the t
now you know the black panther party did
not represent a threat on the
issue of guns what was the threat that
we represented
we had an agenda to understand that the
reason we remained oppressed in america
was because there was this
fundamental 400 year old existing
system that had oppressed us as a group
in the beginning
and so therefore the only way that we
could be free was
that this whole system had to be
dismantled now that's what we understood
and i
absolutely know that fresh hampton
understood everything
so the the limitation the narrow
pathetic
two-dimensional characterization of fred
that was nothing
compared to who fred hampton was to puts
fred into
any context with this piece of garbage
william o'neill this guy was on screen
as much as fred hampton
so what you've done is make him like the
other side
of fresh hampton like there's fred
hampton and then there's
uh william o'neill william o'neill had
no such significance
in the history of either the party or
black people and this is so
insulting to the history of the fred
hampton
much less the black panther party to
equate these men as though they were
two sides of the coin you know well one
turned out this way one no
this was a fight for black people and
our liberation if you had been
respectful of that history then you
might have
shown more respect to not only fred
hampton but to the black panther party
we want full-fledged membership in the
black panther party and none of that
okay
sugar as long as you play the background
getting my beer and rubbing my feet
[ __ ] either
you dig those sisters standing there
looking tough we're going to be at a
party you know who the hell did that
just it's downright slow nobody did that
and to make the point that women were
equal
i mean it just wasn't something that
even
came up there were women in the black
transfer party from day
one erica huggins was one of the first
members in l.a
and when i joined she was my captain so
we had women in leadership
almost from the beginning that i can
recall i don't know where that's coming
from and it's kind of insulting
to both the men and the party and um
to the party's fundamental belief system
and an ideology
well absolutely the black panther party
for self-defense calls for the american
people in general
and black people in particular say
careful note of the racist california
legislature now considering the mall for
that
so this is the first and only time the
national rifle association
supported a gun control bill which is
very funny
so some black people started talking
about carrying guns and all this was was
what is now called open carry because at
that time in california you could carry
a shotgun
that was part of our organizing to say
we have the right to bear arms you want
to say white people have the right to
bear arms
so as soon as we assume that second
amendment right as
all these organizations like to claim uh
oh all of a sudden we have to have gun
control
so it was an impressive moment and
a lot of people were shocked by it
that black people not only that we had
guns but we were not there as thugs
we were there as with an ideological
drive as huey newton used to say the gun
the gun is not necessarily revolutionary
because the police have done so we know
it's not a revolutionary act
but in this case it's the ideology
behind the gun
and that ideology is the championing of
the right of self-defense
under a the larger agenda of
seeking liberation for black people
[Music]
i love gnc birds and i knew her very
well
very well i saw pieces of this uh
stupid movie but the scenes i saw were
just so inaccurate and and so
disrespectful of gene and who she was
hollywood was a big supporter of the
black panther party in our chapter
in southern california we knew every
hollywood star because at that moment we
were the flavor of the year you know
one of our biggest supporters was a guy
named burt schneider who
made a film called easy rider and of
course
jane fonda so the la chapter we were
sort of a sign to go and see her
because this was money that could come
into the black panther party
that's why i know so much about jean
sieber i remember when ultimately my
baby was born she sent me a card and
some baby clothes
stuff like this she was a really
genuinely decent and good person
if bringing them here raises their
profile and it draws attention to the
cause and i've done my job she said she
wanted to support
us but she didn't want to be open about
it because she felt that if she were
that she would never get work in
hollywood and that she would
not be able to support us there for and
so um she would
give donations of 10 to 15 000
you know which would go to northern
california up to northern california and
be spent on
you know food production of our
newspaper what have you
we've tapped our phones in los angeles
they're listening i can hear these
little clicks on the line
i mean we were all aware that we assumed
phones were being tapped nobody was
unconscious but
um i don't think we understood the
magnitude of what was up against which
was the entire united states government
and there was a paranoia that if you
want to call it that but you know
paranoia isn't afraid that we're afraid
of imaginary things this wasn't
this was nothing to nothing imaginary in
it
but she definitely lost everything angry
their point was to discredit the black
panther party gene was certainly
you know collateral damage of casualty
i don't think this film in any way
gives credibility to gene's commitment
to the ideals of the party espoused
that's why i have problems with these
films is because that even though they
get black people to sort of
take over the film the black panther
party remains
demonized mischaracterized
in the public imagery that hollywood
produces